bonjour anastasia chapeau shkin à merci
de répondre à france 24 vous êtes maître
de conférences en géopolitique à
sciences po spécialiste des relations
europe russie et présidente de ce think
tank eastern circles on a du mal à
croire encore en 2022 qu'une guerre
éclate en europe en vaille à l'ukraine
finalement pourquoi faire c'est quoi le
but ultime
le but de vladimir poutine qui l'a déjà
déclaré dans sa déclaration écrite du 17
décembre qu'il a répété à plusieurs
reprises à l'oral si lors des
différentes réunions des conseils en
termes de gouvernement russe ainsi que
des conférences de presse et les
adresses un peu plus qu'on a entendu
depuis lundi c'est revoir l'architecturé
de la sécurité en europe
le cren est en train d'être envahir
c'est cette une étape mais les demandes
russe vers le temps ne se sont pas
arrêtés à l'ukraine il n'était même pas
centré sur vos craintes du tout dans les
démons qui n'ont jamais changé
d'ailleurs après tout la mairie et
diplomatiques et qu'on a observée depuis
deux derniers mois les demandes reste le
même ils comprennent aussi des
comportements de temps le petit monde le
temps à l'est de l'europe est à 7 toutes
les opérations militaires a complètement
transparente bien préparé et des banques
et qui sait que u2 devant devant
monsieur
ce n'est pas tout les préparatifs de la
en tant que de 30 ans conteste pour voir
déjà pour l'occident réagi et ensuite
quelles sont donc des possibilités
d'action pour pour la suite bien sûr
comme moi c'était un bouquet de fleurs
c'est pas que la russie qui fait sa
faiblesse le plus important aussi et
peut avoir des répercussions pas
seulement au niveau européen mais au
niveau mondial à part l'alliance entre
la russie et la chine l'alliance
diplomatique qui aujourd'hui qu'ils se
manifestent relation unique manifeste
dans des proclamations de l'autunois et
qui aura des conséquences par seconde
vannes mais pour l'or la révision de
l'ordre de la sécurité mondiale il ya
une menace que la chine et la russie
fasse alliance même alliance militaire
aujourd'hui à un alliance militaire on
ne sait pas parce que du coup les
audiences mais des terrains s'y sent
bien fait c'est pas forcément toujours
mais alors voilà ça on a bien sûr que
n'a aucun signe de l'alliance militaire
ouverte mais on sait que la chine et la
russie ont fait plusieurs en exercice
militaire ensemble depuis dernière
quelques ans s'est fait toujours de
manière démonstrative et pour montrer le
rapprochement des deux pays mais surtout
ce qui est plus important dans le centre
de l'alliance pour moi c'est le lien
diplomatique aujourd'hui à ce jour qui
est certain déjà parce que des objectifs
dans la politique étrangère de la russie
de la chine considère en ce qui concerne
annexion de nouvelles territoire ou
si on peut dire entre guillemets en
utilisant d'autres discours l'heure
autour des territoires historiques et la
complainte commence par le retrouve ni
retour historique bien sûr ça continue
parce qu'on a entendu parler par la
dénazification c'est à dire ah voilà il
y aura des personnes ciblées qui vont
être qui je vais tuer en ukraine quand
de
maintenant et à cette touche une crainte
cette classe de population extrêmement
important parce que la société civile
une crème très
donc ça c'est peu et ensuite elle me
suit ses avoirs est ce que si le temps
ne répondent que avec les mots à
l'invasion du pays de 42 millions de
personnes est ce que le temps a va
vraiment répondre autrement à l'invasion
d'un pays de 1 million de personnes de
3000 personnes parce que selon le
discours officiel russe les états baltes
est-ce qu'ils existent eux aussi
justement il pourrait y avoir des
répliques pour le reste de l'europe de
l'est on voit bien que la pologne la
lituanie
notamment s'inquiètent ces anciennes
républiques soviétiques la moldavie
aussi avec la transnistrie qui est un un
conflit gelé depuis des années
oui nankin à moldavie la géorgie
bien sûr sont les deux pays à surveiller
de près dans les médias parce que déjà
dans les troupes le mode de vie est
vraiment donne
le cercle immédiat est même déjà des
troupes russes qui sont stationnés en
permanence en transnistrie depuis des
années et qui peut donc être aussi faire
affaires à faire sujet à la continuation
de cette
opération militaire s'il n'utilise le
monde leur patine et ensuite la géorgie
a peut-être aussi parce que du coup
c'était aujourd'hui on observe a
exactement les mêmes a les mêmes
méthodes qui ont utilisé a été utilisé
en géorgie en 2008 c'était exactement
donc incapacité à de l'armée géorgienne
était les ciblages des données décès du
militaire en géorgie et ensuite par
contre en géorgie des poupées russes se
sont arrêtés juste devant des décisions
kiev en ukraine c'est pas forcément à
sera leur scénario parce que selon
toutes les sensations uniques heures en
un temps le monde et une acidification
en attend donc le monde- à
agressions contre la population qui est
considéré un tir us et en ukraine
aujourd'hui vue de l'opinion publique ça
peut sembler des
l'europe s'inquiète aussi pour un autre
pays
la bosnie avec des visées
sécessionnistes de la part de l'entité
serbe qui semble être soutenue aussi par
moscou
je ne serai pas
aujourd'hui
vous voulez dire
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui il ya des des
ambitions sécessionnistes
en bosnie
aujourd'hui je serais pas répondre à
cette question d'honneur d'accord
peut-être un mot sur les occidentaux on
voit bien qu'ils sont impuissants à part
des grandes déclarations à parler les
sanctions ces menaces sur l'économie sur
l'économie russe d'abord est-ce que vous
pensez que les occidentaux ont eu tort
de ne pas bouger en 2014 quand la russie
a annexé la crimée et si oui il aurait
pu faire quoi
déjà donc toutes les occidentaux
en vue de l'histoire aujourd'hui donc
c'est facile à dire sept îles et devait
bouger déjà la première erreur et cette
erreur est commise a malheureusement
aujourd'hui on ne le voit remise c'était
que les dépenses et de l'occident à
l'ukraine était de ne pas tirer de
rester calme et de ne surtout pas
provoquer les russes donc ça ça a permis
à l'occupation du commun et l'adduction
sans aucun problème et sans aucune
résistance parce que justement les
militaires craignant des données l'ordre
par leur gouvernement de ne pas résister
à l'action quand même s'ils étaient sur
place macheist des moments nombreux
qu'eux mais ensuite donc cette même
conseil a été donné cette fois ci est
bien sûr le militaires craignant l'armée
ukrainienne qui est là en train de se
refaire depuis huit ans et elle était
sur place était positionné mais on a vu
que la localisation général commence que
après le début de l'invasion ont bien
sûr cet art essayez de suivi du conseil
de l'occident a donc du coup ce qui est
qui qui est repéré le s'il s'agit de
l'après guerre qu'est ce que l'occident
pouvait faire en 2014 bien sûr vous
pouvez réagir avec des vraies sanctions
en 2014 des sanctions beaucoup plus
dures de son pardon
mais aussi surtout c'est
surtout
l'asse c'est une chose mais aujourd'hui
surtout on a cette même à
ce que ça me gênerait le play est un peu
ce qu'on a vu que même en allemagne et
en allemagne après la deuxième guerre
mondiale la donne dans le
face à face entre eux pendant la guerre
froide entre l'occident et elle a lieu
c'est l'éthique ce qui est fait en mon
en certains endroits
les groupes américains les troupes
occidentales et stationner c'est jacques
poujol et sous très peur aux endroits et
ça c'était donc c'est mon exemple que si
elle me celui qui tire au-dessus il tire
pas sur les allemands n'étaient pas sur
des bocaux et tirent sur les miens car
direct donc ça provoque automatiquement
les résistances de
aujourd'hui cette position donc même le
choix de l'occident de retirer l'option
militaire de la table bien sûr en course
extrêmement les positions de la russie
la russie c'est que quoi qu'elle fasse
elle ne va pas avoir des conséquences
militaires grâce à son agression
militaire et les conséquences
économiques quoi qu'on voit quand on
observe ce lait sur les marchés on
observe bien de coups vous de voir que
le prix du pétrole est en cours depuis
2014 c'est à dire que les revenus de la
russie via nantes dollars et les
dépenses en réussite de la russie reste
en roubles et quand le rouble il baisse
du coup ça renforce l'état russe ils ont
de l'argent ils n'ont plus peut-être un
même vêtement part d'entre elles ont
duré de l'accès à cette système
financier ils ont ainsi préparé pour les
sanctions pendant très longtemps et
maintenant quant à la guerre a dérivé on
a essayé de répondre à un kalachnikov
avec un billet d'euros ça marche pas
comme ça voilà donc
on en a pas que très très limitées voire
aucune mais remercie en tout cas
anastasia chapeau chine à nous avoir
éclairé maître de conférences en
géopolitique à sciences po et
spécialiste des relations russie